- Hi, I'm Dave Travis, I'm
the Test Prep Content Manager
at Khan Academy.
It's especially challenging
when you make a mistake
again, and again, and again,
and you know that you did it wrong,
you know immediately
when you did it, that,
oh, I did that thing again,
and I need to fix that,
I need to go back and
fix it and iron it out,
and get it smooth, and there's
a motto that I like a lot,
which is very simple, which is,
the more you do it, the better you get.
And I heard somewhere that you
actually need to do a skill
for 10,000 hours if you
really wanna get good
and that's true with martial
arts, it's true with ceramics,
it's true with writing,
it's true with a language,
it's true with musical instrument.
If you wanna get good at
something it takes time
and you need to be patient with yourself,
you need to trust yourself
and trust that your brain
can do these things.
And just because you bump up against
a frustration or a challenge,
that's an opportunity to grow,
it's an opportunity to develop a skill
that you didn't have before.
I think, you know, one of
the things that's exciting
about learning a new skill
is that the more you do it,
not only the better you get,
the more fun you have doing it,
it can be hard to have a fun time
when you're learning
the basics of, you know,
grammar in French, or
you're learning how to ski
and you're falling over all the time.
But the more you actually do those things
and you improve your skills,
it actually becomes more fun
because you gain confidence,
you gain
you gain an ability to
look back at what you've
accomplished, and say,
"You know what, last week I
was making all these mistakes,
"and now I actually get this,
"and now I can actually
build upon this skill
"and do more than I was
able to do last week."